[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on l'appelle l'homme en feu un homme en
feu sous la mer une belle idée
paradoxal l'idée d'un homme qui décida
un jour que l'ars avait aussi sa place
dans les océans
[Musique]
ans
il y a des gens comme ça qui vont au
bout de leur passion des gens capables
de tenir à bout de bras les projets les
plus fous
jason taylor a su marier ses deux amours
la plongée sous-marine et la sculpture
[Musique]
le parc marin de cancun au mexique lui a
passé une commande des mesures et la
création et la mise à l'eau de 400
statues c'est elles sont presque toutes
là dans l'atelier en cours de
fabrication en attente avant d'aller
bientôt rejoindre celles qui sont déjà
posés au fond de l'eau
[Musique]
ans
le
[Musique]
mais pour l'instant on est en plein
processus de fabrication
avant cela il y a eu des mois de travail
pour choisir les modèles réalisés les
empreintes les moulages
pensez aux moindres détails
cet endroit est fréquemment touchée par
les ouragans
il faut donc renforcer la structure on
les attache entre elles pour qu'elles ne
tombent pas les conditions sont dures
il fait très chaud il ya des moustiques
on se déshydrate
le travail est très physique le ciment
est lourd et vous brûle les mains quand
je parle avec mes amis en angleterre il
croit que je me la coule douce avec un
verre de piña colada sur la plage tu
peux bouger et l'attention parce que mon
bras est à l'intérieur
diplômé des beaux-arts de londres
l'artiste anglais est désormais
directeur du musée sous marin de cancun
elle mode c'est aussi bakwa tiko il a
engagé des artistes de la région pour le
second des photographes sculpteurs ou
peintres rodrigo lui organise d'habitude
des expositions et des installations
très avant gardiste
elles sont à caussade noir à 100 mba et
l'océan
c'est une chose nouvelle devant l'océan
comme un musée perd ses intérêts des
statues colossales et ailleurs mais on
n'a jamais considéré la mer comme un
musée concert c'est ce qui me plaît le
plus c'est un peu comme l'art de la rue
[Musique]
et comme c'est ici c'est les
collectionneurs des rêves perdus
là ce sont de vieilles photos et ça
c'est la réplique de la sculpture qui
est sous l'eau l'idée c'est que c'est un
archiviste sous-marin qui conserve les
bouteilles qu'on trouve dans la mer
message il trouve des rêves qui flottent
dans l'océan
les bouteilles nous ont vraiment été
envoyés du monde entier par différentes
associations
c'est un besoin de trois groupes
aujourd'hui visite à l'atelier des
élèves d'un collège local
tout le monde va servir de modèle pour
le nouveau projet cette fois jason a
seulement besoin de leurs oreilles une
fois qu'on a le moule on le remplit de
ciment puis on va les réunir pour faire
un arbre qu'on appellera l'arbre qui
écoute
l'idée c'est qu'au lieu d'entendre des
voix humaine qui dicte tout qui parle
tout le temps
au lieu de ça thorzain écoute le fond de
la mer
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est une idée
merveilleuse si on peut arriver à marier
l'art des humains avec la nature
complexe
oui
on vise police et tous les personnages
que vous voyez ici ont tous des bouleaux
différence chez elle elle est prof de
yoga en ville et lui c'est un garde du
parc marin tous ensemble ils forment une
représentation de la société mexicaine
des crises comme celle traditionnelle
dont les sculptures célébrer un voix ou
une personnalité importante
là il s'agit de célébrer les vrais gens
ce qu'ils font un vrai travail essentiel
pour la société il s'agit des nôtres et
de les immortaliser
elle est figée dans la pierre
[Musique]
voilà
jason vie à puerto morelos un petit port
à 25 km au sud de cancun pas encore
grignoté par le béton avec jason tout le
monde peut gagner sa minute de gloire
comme charlie brown un pêcheur qui aime
bien l'idée de passer l'éternité au fond
de l'océan bien douze chaires libre aux
12 1 avec toi ça va faire 13 sur les
bras on a peur tout morello merci c'est
pas un peu trop non ouais non je trouve
pas que ce soit trop et ça me plaît
[Musique]
voilà
certains visages nous rappellent qu'ici
dans le yucatan les mayas régner avant
l'arrivée des espagnols
[Musique]
jason a voulu leur rendre hommage avec
hector un autre modèle j'aime bien
l'idée de représenter le peuple maya je
porte des boucles d'oreilles un sac de
haricot comme un paysan maya maya
ça me plaît beaucoup pour faire le
modèle il faut un peu de concentration
effet on peut se sentir claustrophobe
pour le moulage technique une date qui
durcissent et durent longtemps
c'est difficile de respirer et sean m'a
donné une position très fatigante à
tenir avec les bras comme ça
[Musique]
si le parc marin a fait appel aux
services du sculpteur anglais ce n'est
pas seulement pour faire joli au fond de
la mer mais avant tout pour protéger les
récifs coralliens des environs de cancun
bref dans un but écologique
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de couvrir une importante
surface de fonds marins et d'offrir à la
faune des endroits où nagent et les
poissons peuvent se réfugier dans les
statuts de la matière et la composition
du ciment ont été conçus pour encourager
la fixation des cours
notre but c'est de créer un énorme
récifs artificiels fait chauray
et pourquoi la station balnéaire de
cancun doit elle sauver son corail
soleil chaleur et meurent turquoise pour
les 4 millions de visiteurs annuels
voilà la recette de cancun un alignement
de 25 km2 building en bord de mer de
nouveau temple érigé à la va vite sur la
terre des mayas qui vit désormais au
rythme des vacances américaines
voilà
[Applaudissements]
mais cancun possède aussi la réputation
d'être un des premiers centres mondiaux
de plongée sous marine
remarquez que vous allez plonger dans un
parc national c'est très important
vous n'avez pas le droit de ramasser
quoi que ce soit sur le récif vous ne
les touchez pas gardez vos distances
eh oui ici on plonge dans un parc marin
un espace protégé
enfin en principe huit cent mille
personnes chaque année veulent découvrir
le récif et presque tous les plongeurs
sont des débutants
résultat ce sont ces visiteurs qui
perturbent la vie marine une
fréquentation effréné ajouté là dessus
des ouragans toujours plus fort ces
dernières années et les coraux souffrent
et meurent le parc marin cherché à
détourner les plongeurs des sites
coralliens les plus fragiles l'idée d'un
musée sous-marin a germé quand ils ont
découvert les premières réalisations de
jason sur internet
et ça marche les touristes viennent déjà
admirer les premières statues installées
au large
[Musique]
les scientifiques prévoient que dans 50
ans on va perdre 80 % de nos corps ou
quand j'aurai 75 ou 80 ans qu'est ce que
je vais dire à mes petits enfants
c'était magnifique mais on a tout
détruit
ma génération a tout détruit je pense
pas pouvoir vivre avec ça jason prend
lui même soin des parties vivante de ses
statuts rendez vous sur la jardinière de
l'espérance
entouré de ses plantations j'ai planté
du corail vivant dans chaque pot c'est
une méthode de conservation
le corail a été brisé par les tempêtes
ou des touristes
tu prends des petites pousses comme on
fait dans un jardin où il sert de le
replanter et le corail va se multiplier
et grandir obtient toujours les autres
paraissent plus grand plus proche que
sur terre les perspectives sont
différentes
la lumière change tout le temps ça fesse
les mouvements de la surface de l'eau se
reflète sur la sculpture
reste une inconnue
que deviennent les statuts après un long
séjour dans l'océan pour voir cette
évolution il faut entreprendre un voyage
dans le temps
oh
[Musique]
nous voici à la grenade une petite île
des caraïbes
c'est mon salut comment ça va arranger
ça va très bien ça fait plaisir de te
revoir
ouais je suis content d'être revenu
[Musique]
ici c'est un peu l'anti cancun pas de
béton pas de tourisme de masse
oui
d'ailleurs une loi interdit tout
bonnement de construire des immeubles
plus haut que les cocotiers
[Musique]
jason revient en terre de connaissance
après quatre années d'absence plongeur
professionnel dans sa première vie après
avoir parcouru toutes les mers du monde
il choisit la grenade pour monter son
propre club
j'étais venu ici dans l'intention de
reprendre une affaire est en fait au
début le parc de sculptures étaient
plutôt un genre de audi c'était ta
passion côté il fallait une affaire qui
me procure un revenu
là c'était ma maison sur la droite
encore une sculpture sur la porte du
garage regardes tu vois j'ai encore des
éléments de moulage et puis rapidement
gisèle se rend compte qu'il n'est pas
vraiment fait pour le business et
abandonne le projet de club
les projets échoué je ne savais vraiment
pas quoi faire de ma vie
le bon côté c'est que ça a été
libérateur et je me suis dit si tu es
complètement paumé et la faune et fais
ce que tu aimes
j'ai commencé à faire des sculptures
petite visite chez fils devenu le
gardien des statuts depuis le départ de
cesena
les sculptures sont super bons la ronde
d'enfants bien chaud j'ai sonné mois ont
partagé un appartement jessen m'a dit
regarde mon ordinateur
on a dit je ne savais pas ce qu'il a
montré à j'ai vu des sculptures j'ai dit
ouais c'est bien je m'y connais pas
tellement là je lui dise ça a l'air pas
mal qui a fait ça il a dit c'est moi et
il m'a dit qu'est ce que tu penserais de
mettre ses statuts sous l'eau ça a été
comme une illumination
j'ai dis tout de suite je sais
exactement où on peut les mettre la b2
molinières n'est pas loin du port de
saint georges la capitale lilliputienne
là se trouvent les premières
réalisations de jason du temps où il
avait seulement quelques copains pour
l'aider
il va enfin découvrir le travail des ans
des courants et de la vie marine
[Musique]
c'est vraiment génial de revoir
certaines de ses sculptures de voir les
changements
je suis juste en admiration devant le
travail de la nature
il ya toutes sortes de plantes marines
toutes sortes d'algues des éponges qui
filtrent l'eau
m
celui ci est recouvert d'une éponge
magnifique rose bonbon espagne le luxe
comme on dirait qu'il a de l'acné ou une
maladie honteuse
[Musique]
même si j'essayais jamais je ne pourrai
reproduire les patines créé par la
nature c'est ça qui est merveilleux
il ya du corail qui a poussé dans une
corbeille à fruits s'ajoutent de la
matière
les femmes couché dans le sable c'est
intéressant le sable est recouverte et
pour bien les voir il faut les brosses
et c'est comme une découverte
archéologique on pense à une
civilisation disparue en fait elles
n'ont que quatre ans
le groupe de visage dans les rochers a
été réalisé avec une école locale
c'est peu profonds ici c'est un peu fait
exprès pour permettre aux gens du coin
de venir les voir ce sont surtout des
gens d'ici qui sont représentés
quand jason a débarqué en 2005 à la
grenade le pays venait d'être frappé par
un ouragan
les lieux dévastés ont nourri
l'inspiration du sculpteur retour dans
ce que fut le centre de la télévision
nationale où la nature a repris ses
droits
[Musique]
ce genre de bâtiment s'il le fait c'est
le même sentiment de soul au funk earth
c'est comme un espace oublier qu'ils
évoluent qui change les murs sont
couverts de matières de mousse c'est
organique
c'est aussi là qu'il venait dénicher
certains des éléments de ses sculptures
machine à écrire bureau déglingué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un homme devant une machine à écrire il
y a quinze ou vingt ans c'était très
court en croit maintenant ça ressemble à
une étrange molik la changer si
rapidement dans les 15 20 dernières
années
je pense qu'on a tous un sentiment de
perte et on n'arrive pas à le comprendre
quelques-unes de mes sculptures temps de
retrouver ces moments là
[Applaudissements]
oh
et puis à l'automne dernier au large de
cancun les statuts en prêt la mer des
jours durant
les hommes ont lutté contre la houle
pour placer d'autres hommes immobiles et
silencieux cela dans l'éternité des
océans
à
ans
oh
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]